beispiel com es ist alles deins jetzt
kann es endlich einen draufmachen
250.000 ja was soll man sagen wollte ist
einfach sagt hallo realistisches
szenario 18 jährige jungen frauen
gewinnt 250.000 dollar beim broker dass
das sind fälle wie gibt es tausendfach
in deutschland jedes jahr
meine damen und herren ich war in den
letzten tagen wieder in den weiten des
internets unterwegs besonders auf dem
youtube-kanal unserer geliebten
qualitäts fernsehsendungen hilf mir und
habe dabei eine folge entdeckt die ich
euch auf gar keinen fall vorenthalten
möchte wir schauen uns heute zusammen
poker class style und das geld an ich
glaube ich muss gar nicht so viel sagen
heute hat einen blick auf das thumbnail
zeit uns schon sehr deutlich dass wir
uns heute wieder in eine sphäre maximale
ehren losigkeit begeben ich würd sagen
gelangen dann gar nicht angekommen
werfen auch ein blick in die
beschreibung und dann geht's los
wie schön wir das ist ein ganz normales
leben zu führen in einem intakten
elternhaus mit genügend geldtasche und
kumpeln mit denen man abhängen kann klar
ist 18 hat das alles nicht sein vater
nie kennengelernt in der schule gemobbt
und wenigstens ein wenig geld zu haben
muss im hotel job
doch eines tages wendet sich das blatt
klar ist gewinnt 250.000 poken und lernt
überdies carsten 38 kennen den als
mentor unter seine fittiche nimmt ma
besitzer vermittelt dem schülerhort
animiert ihn jetzt endlich mal
ordentlich auf den putz zu hauen
alles klar bleibt für diese folge leute
ich hoffe wir auch macht euch gefasst
auf nackte männer heiße frauen und viel
geld
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was rät oppel ich glaube es gibt auch
den verschiedenen hilf mir redakteuren
ein wettbewerb darum wer am schnellsten
in einer folge einen moment verpacken
kann an die man schon einfach
lachend aus dem fenster springen möchte
der autor von dieser folge hatte schon
sehr gut hinbekommen
der zeitstempel sagt 0 14 und wir sehen
einen kräftigen monatlich den raum
rennen perfekt
okay das ist der poker tisch und verein
in dem er 250.000 euro gewandert ich
muss sagen das sieht doch alles sehr
professionell aus auf jeden fall wir
haben im hintergrund ein lautsprecher
aus 1931 30 warum erkannt hat so einen
mitspieler also klar es hat einen gegner
an dieser pokerrunde das ist
selbstverständlich ein ort an dem man
mal eben 250.000 euro gewinnt ja eher
leute ich muss sagen da wurden wieder
mal keine kosten und mühen gescheut um
die besten darsteller und die besten
drehorte sowie natürlich auch das
absolut hochwertiges 10 design am start
zu haben um dem zuschauer ein gefühl zu
geben dass das hier wirklich gerade
passiert mal ganz davon abgesehen da
kennen wir hier auch schon im
gesichtsausdruck von dem tätowierten
dealer also pferde die karten aus und
beim poker dass er jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon bereut hier mitgemacht zu haben
also im ernst ich bin jetzt kein poker
experte aber sollten im turnier wurde so
eine viertelmillion euro oder eier geht
nicht ein bisschen mehr aufwand da sein
vielleicht so kann also so große
preisgelder wenn ihr nicht endlich im
fernsehen verspielt und ein kamerateam
ok kamerateam ist da zwei kamerateams
ja aber ich muss sagen genauso wie ich
mir das vorgestellt auf jeden fall
seriöser laden muss man sagen einfach so
250.000 euro in dem kauf war offen
herumstehen keine security keine
sicherheiten dafür falls wir jemand das
geld klauen will einfach mit vier
millionen koffer was soll passieren und
er natürlich auch sehr realistisch nimmt
etwa den koffer mit 250.000 euro und
macht einfach spazieren geselle wundern
uns dass jetzt wirklich kommt schon
hilft mir hätte ein bisschen mehr zeit
geben können okay
er ist gerade mal zwei sekunden mit
seinem kopf herum gelaufen schon kommen
diese komischen buschtrommel youtube
geriet gelötet und irgendwas geht der
trend im hinterher
28 sekunden
[Applaus]
an der szene kam jetzt natürlich
überhaupt nichts kritisieren man muss
wirklich anerkennen dass beide hier mit
maximaler geschwindigkeit gerannt sind
ich muss sagen wenn ich ein koffer mit
der filter millionen der hand hätte ich
könnte auch zeitlich schneller als das
[Applaus]
heute im ernst es ist langsam ist schon
klar dass du hast eine viertelmillion in
diesem koffer
das ist kein langstreckenlauf zur
vorbereitung von marathon ganz langsam
rennt auch einfach ok und an der stelle
sehen wir auch auf jeden fall dass der
räuber glücklicherweise keine
ähnlichkeiten zu seinem vorherigen
konkurrenten beim pokern hat die haben
auch gar keinen fall den gleichen
polieren beste was heute genau für
dieses phänomen brauchen wir einen
begriff das was ihr gerade irgendwie
gesehen haben ist das klassische hilf
mir kleine welt syndrom was meine ich
damit ganz einfach ich glaube die
allermeisten hilf mir folgen ist das
budget wahrscheinlich etwas beschränkter
deswegen kaufen auch wenn in der ganzen
stadt gedreht wird immer nur so drei
menschen auf kann sein dass sie ein
video in berlin oder in münchen dreht
egal
in der folge kommen nur drei menschen
vor mein gott ich habe schulden ohne
ende ich habe mein ganzes geld gerade
verzockt
ok ja überzeugen auf jeden fall von dem
räuber an der stelle er hatte und ende
hat sein komplettes geld verzockt gut
das hat dann gesagt so dann geht auch
versuchen so klas erstmal auszumachen
irgendwie eine waffe mitzunehmen oder
oder noch mal den koffer zu schnappen
wir beide aus zulagen keine ahnung ist
ihm egal er ist einfach so ja okay jetzt
habe ich ja gesagt kann ich alles machen
okay ich gehe kann ich einfach dazu
etwas sagen können ich wollte nach hause
einfach wie du willst zu hause mann du
hast knapp 250.000 euro gewonnen
findest du dich oder habt ihr auch das
gefühl dass er hier viel er so aussieht
als würde das ausrauben als ich weiß
nicht so heißt tattoos so breit gepumpt
du musst das feiern einen draufmachen
feiern eigentlich nicht so gemeint hast
nicht so machen du bist 18
es gab so ein haufen kohle geworden man
muss jetzt mal ein bisschen das leben
genießen hat hinter tumor bisschen
totenkopf im ohr klingt wieder menschen
leute aber er gibt mir nicht so den weit
ab dass er so der perfekt der
anlageberater wäre also dass er doch ein
zuhälter oder man macht es ganz auf
jeden fall sehen ja als 18 jähriger der
gerade eine viertel million gewonnen hat
und ba mit sich herumträgt sollte man
sich auf jeden fall einem zuhälter mit
tattoo im ohr an vertrauen mit einer der
sichersten methoden sein geld
langfristig nicht zu behalten
möglichkeiten das geld auszugeben und
vor allem mit 80.000 anführungszeichen
zu gefallen wusste ja ich glaube an
diesem punkt hätte er umdrehen sollen
klar das wird nicht gut für die enden
aber etwas beschweren weil es eigentlich
selbst wenn es für klaas an dieser folge
nicht gut enden sollte können wir alle
wenn wir mit der alltäglichen
situationen konfrontiert sind dass sie
mal eben eine viertelmillion war einem
dubiosen poker turnier gewinnen genau
wissen was wir zu tun haben und was
nicht
ich muss erst einmal artikels im hilfen
wir uns hingesetzt zitieren jede folge
von hilf mir jungen pleite verzweifelt
beschreibt ein problem wie er da steht
immer noch der probleme das ist das
problem wie es im leben eines teenagers
passieren könnte sollte endlich ist die
lösung da alle eure freunde die sich mal
gefragt haben mensch jetzt habe ich auch
eine viertelmillion im poker spielen
gewonnen was mache ich denn jetzt damit
die dumme leute schon daher rief mir da
gibt's für eure alltäglichen probleme
immer eine lösung
ich mach dich locker
ich kann es dadurch stellen nur noch mal
wiederholen leute wenn ihr oder eure
vielzähligen freunde die auch eine
viertelmillion kuba gewonnen haben sich
fragen was sie machen sollten vertraut
euch keine zuhälter passieren aber auch
keine hässlichen einmal aber es
existiert nein
ja was soll man sagen wollte ist einfach
selbst ein realistisches szenario 18
jährige jungen frau gewinnt 250.000
dollar beim broker dass das sind fälle
wie gibt es tausendfach in deutschland
jedes jahr geht es überhaupt dass ich so
ein 0 arbeit in irgend einer erzählung
von der vorgeschichte gesteckt wurde
die ganze vorgeschichte das klar sowie
gemobbt wurde dass er keine ahnung nicht
viel geld hatte stellenbeschreibung
vorspannen das in der beschreibung leute
das ist es dann auch so das war von
dieser fall würde der zweite teil kommt
morgen ich kann mich jetzt mal
versprechen es wird nicht angenehm
werden aber unterhaltsam sektor
erscheine das video auf und startet
morgen wir ein um die volle story zu
genießen